This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you've ever flipped through the radio dial, not satellite, not podcasts, but good old-fashioned AM and FM radio, you may have noticed something. First of all, don't stop believing, it still gets a shocking amount of airtime. It's a great song, but maybe culture should evolve. But also, when it comes to talk radio, a lot of it sounds kind of the same. Can I just be on this highway for a while so it'll take a good time to see what's on the radio?
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果你曾经拨动过收音机旋钮——不是卫星广播，也不是播客，而是那种老派的调幅（AM）和调频（FM）广播——你可能已经注意到了某些现象。首先，“Don't Stop Believin'”这首歌的播放频率高得惊人。这确实是一首好歌，但也许文化也该进步了。此外，谈话类广播听起来大多千篇一律。我能在这条高速公路上多待一会儿，好看看收音机里都在播什么吗？
Oh yeah. That is Katie Thornton, reporter and friend of the show, and total radio nerd. She started working behind the scenes at radio stations when she was just a teenager. Whenever I go on road trips, like this one earlier this year from Minneapolis down to Memphis, or even just sitting around at home, I always let the radio be my companion. But for the years I've spent surfing the radio dial, it's always been clear that on talk radio, one style and one political perspective tends to dominate.
噢，当然。那是凯蒂·桑顿，她是本节目的记者、朋友，也是个彻头彻尾的广播迷。她十几岁时就开始在广播电台做幕后工作了。每当我进行公路旅行时，比如今年早些时候从明尼阿波利斯到孟菲斯的旅程，或者只是在家里闲坐，我总是让广播陪伴我。但在我多年拨动收音机旋钮的经验中，有一点始终很明确：在谈话类广播中，往往只有一种风格和一种政治视角占据主导地位。
I'm going to keep surfing now. Right wing talk radio is everywhere across the US It's not uncommon for talk radio in cities and small towns alike to sound like this racial profiling is good for your health with the COVID pandemic gender confusion is being driven by societal Mania drill build the Keystone pipeline deport, build the wall, defy the federal government. As of this fall, 17 of the country's 20 biggest radio talk hosts were conservative. Only one was progressive. And that matters, because broadcast radio is still a really important medium.
我现在要继续搜台了。右翼谈话广播在美国随处可见。在城市和小城镇，谈话广播听起来像这样并不罕见：种族定性对你的健康有益；新冠疫情期间，性别困惑是由社会狂热驱动的；钻探石油；修建基石输油管道；驱逐移民；筑墙；反抗联邦政府。截至今年秋季，全美排名前20的广播谈话节目主持人中，有17位是保守派。只有一位是进步派。这很重要，因为广播电台仍然是一种非常重要的媒介。
It has a higher reach than television. It's nearly neck and neck with social media for how Americans get their news. And in studies, it often ranks as the media format that Americans trust the most. Katie has just released a new five-part podcast series with WNYC's on the media about how one side of political spectrum came to dominate broadcast radio
它的覆盖面比电视更广。在获取新闻的渠道上，它与社交媒体几乎不相上下。在多项研究中，它常被评为美国人最信任的媒体形式。凯蒂刚刚与WNYC的《On the Media》节目合作发布了一个五集播客系列，探讨了政治光谱的一端是如何主导广播电台的。
and how one company is using the airwaves to launch a right-wing media empire. Katie's series is called The Divided Dial, and it's out now. Today on our show, we wanted to talk with Katie about some of the little-known history behind how we got such lopsided airwaves. Okay, Katie, where do we start?
以及一家公司是如何利用电波建立起一个右翼媒体帝国的。凯蒂的系列节目名为《分裂的电波》（The Divided Dial），现已上线。今天在我们的节目中，我们想和凯蒂聊聊关于我们如何陷入这种失衡电波背后一些鲜为人知的历史。好了，凯蒂，我们从哪里开始？
Well, to get into the meat of our story about how the radio dial once had more diverse perspectives and how that arrangement was undone, I want to start in a time when radio sounded pretty different than it does today. This part we're in from around the base, it all comes in to your goodwill station. This is it. WDIA presents the award-winning feature, Brown America Speaks. In the middle of the last century,
嗯，要深入探讨我们的故事，即广播电台曾经如何拥有更多元化的视角，以及这种格局是如何被打破的，我想从一个广播听起来与今天大不相同的时代说起。我们现在所处的这个部分来自基地附近，这一切都归功于你们的善意电台。就是这个。WDIA呈现获奖专题节目《美国黑人心声》（Brown America Speaks）。在上个世纪中叶，
the US radio dial was a rare publicly accessible space that was integrated. I hadn't really thought of it as a place that could or couldn't be integrated, but it makes so much sense. I mean, you could go to the radio and hear thoughts and conversation and music of people that were from different places and different races and different backgrounds. Right. On some stations, a variety of voices could be heard. There was black
美国的广播电台是一个罕见的、种族融合的公共空间。我以前从未想过它是否能实现种族融合，但这确实很有道理。我的意思是，你可以打开收音机，听到来自不同地方、不同种族、不同背景的人们的思想、对话和音乐。没错。在一些电台上，可以听到各种各样的声音。有黑人的
talk radio and music, some religious shows, some union stations, but it was far from perfect. In the mid-1900s, most radio stations were still white-owned. Largely because at first the government wouldn't even grant broadcast licenses to black or Jewish Americans. And in the middle of the century, there was one movement in particular that was finding it hard to get air time. Mark Lloyd, professor and former Associate General Counsel at the FCC, is going to tell us more. The folks who had money and made determinations
谈话广播和音乐，一些宗教节目，一些工会电台，但它远非完美。在20世纪中叶，大多数广播电台仍由白人拥有。这很大程度上是因为起初政府甚至不会向黑人或犹太裔美国人发放广播执照。而在世纪中叶，有一个运动特别难以获得播出时间。马克·劳埃德，教授兼联邦通信委员会（FCC）前副总法律顾问，将为我们详细介绍。那些有钱并决定
about what got on television or radio were interested in, they were not interested in the appeals of Martin Luther King. I can't say I'm surprised that the early soul rights movement was not getting much air time back then. Exactly. Unfortunately, it's not very surprising. Though I should say this was the golden age of Black radio, with really popular DJs across the country using their influence to promote civil rights and to spread the word about
什么能上电视或广播的人，他们对马丁·路德·金的诉求并不感兴趣。我不得不说，我并不惊讶早期的民权运动在当时没有获得多少播出时间。确实。不幸的是，这并不令人惊讶。尽管我必须说，这是黑人广播的黄金时代，全国各地极具影响力的DJ利用他们的影响力来推动民权运动，并传播关于
demonstrations and marches, but there were a lot of white-owned stations who were determined not to air Black voices. And this was especially true in the South, but in the North as well. They weren't interested in what it was that Thurgood Marshall had to say about the Brown V Board of Education and how he was being implemented in schools. That's not what they wanted to hear. Mark isn't mentioning Thurgood Marshall out of nowhere. In 1955, an incident involving Marshall actually kicked off a legal saga that would prove to be a revolution for radio. Future Supreme Court Justice Marshall
示威和游行的消息，但有很多白人拥有的电台决心不播出黑人的声音。这种情况在南方尤为严重，但在北方也是如此。他们对瑟古德·马歇尔关于“布朗诉教育委员会案”的看法，以及该判决如何在学校实施并不感兴趣。那不是他们想听的。马克提到瑟古德·马歇尔并非无缘无故。1955年，一起涉及马歇尔的事件引发了一场法律传奇，这场传奇后来被证明是广播界的一场革命。未来的最高法院大法官马歇尔
had successfully argued Brown View Board, which desegregated schools. And that fall, in 1955, he was interviewed on NBC. The program was sent out to NBC affiliate stations, but one of those stations, a joint radio and TV station called WLBT in Mississippi, decided they didn't want to run it, and they cut the feed. Wow. And so this was this ideologically motivated interruption. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. It was. The manager of the station was an avowed white supremacist,
成功辩护了“布朗诉教育委员会案”，该案废除了学校的种族隔离。1955年秋，他在NBC接受了采访。节目被发送给NBC的附属电台，但其中一家名为WLBT的密西西比州广播电视合营电台决定不播放该节目，并切断了信号。哇。所以这是一次意识形态驱动的干扰。是的，绝对是。该电台的经理是一位公开的白人至上主义者，
and this was not the only time WLBT refused to cover the civil rights movement, or even just air the voices of black Americans. Black folks in Mississippi and in the Jackson-Mississippi area, which were roughly 40% of the population, were not allowed even by time on the station. And so the folks in the local area were hearing one particular perspective about the civil rights movement. They weren't hearing both sides.
这并不是WLBT唯一一次拒绝报道民权运动，甚至拒绝播出黑人的声音。密西西比州和杰克逊地区约占人口40%的黑人，甚至不被允许在电台上获得播出时间。因此，当地民众只听到了关于民权运动的一种特定观点。他们听不到双方的声音。
This continued into the 1960s at WLBT. In 1963, they cut the NBC feed during coverage of a lunch counter sin in, and repeatedly refused to let civil rights leaders appear on the station. W-A-L-B-T was just one station, but there were many stations in the south that did the same thing, and there were stations in the north that did pretty much the same thing. In the 1960s, the lack of media coverage was so pervasive that civil rights leaders like Martin Luther King started explicitly calling out the lack of media attention and asking allies to help get coverage. And after this call goes out, a liberal-minded church group, the United Church of Christ,
这种情况在WLBT一直持续到20世纪60年代。1963年，他们在报道午餐柜台静坐示威时切断了NBC的信号，并多次拒绝让民权领袖出现在电台上。WLBT只是其中一家电台，但南方有许多电台做了同样的事情，北方也有电台做了几乎同样的事情。在20世纪60年代，媒体报道的缺失是如此普遍，以至于像马丁·路德·金这样的民权领袖开始明确指出媒体关注的缺失，并请求盟友帮助争取报道。在这一呼吁发出后，一个自由派教会团体——基督联合教会，
ends up working with activists, many of whom had long fought for coverage themselves, often unsuccessfully, to try to get more airtime. And to do this, they decided to use some tools that the government themselves had created. All right, so what are those tools and when were they created? Okay, so flashback to the 1920s and the emergence of something called the public interest mandate. Basically, when radio was new, a ton of people wanted to broadcast, the demand for space on the dial outstripped supply. So to narrow the field, the federal government says that any station using the public airwaves
最终与活动人士合作，其中许多人长期以来一直在为争取报道而斗争，但往往以失败告终，试图获得更多的播出时间。为了做到这一点，他们决定使用政府自己创造的一些工具。好的，那么这些工具是什么，它们是什么时候创造的？好吧，让我们闪回到20世纪20年代，当时出现了一种叫做“公共利益授权”的东西。基本上，当广播刚出现时，很多人都想进行广播，对电波空间的需求超过了供应。因此，为了缩小范围，联邦政府规定任何使用公共电波的电台
needs to serve the public interest. What do they mean by the public interest? Yeah, right. It's like super vague, right? But the FCC clarified what it meant by public interest in the years following World War 2. They had seen how radio could be used to promote fascism in Europe, and they did But the FCC clarified what it meant by public interest in the years following World War II. They had seen how radio could be used to promote fascism in Europe, and they didn't want US radio stations to become propaganda outlets.
都需要服务于公共利益。他们所说的公共利益是什么意思？是的，这听起来非常模糊，对吧？但在二战后的几年里，FCC明确了公共利益的含义。他们目睹了广播在欧洲如何被用来宣扬法西斯主义，他们不希望美国的广播电台成为宣传工具。
And so, in 1949, the FCC basically says to stations, in order to serve the public, you need to give airtime to coverage of current events. And you have to include multiple perspectives in your coverage. This is the basis of what comes to be known as the fairness doctrine. So it's the 50s and 60s, the stations. They're cutting the NBC coverage of the civil rights movement.
因此，在1949年，FCC基本上告诉各电台，为了服务公众，你们需要提供时事报道。而且你们必须在报道中包含多种观点。这就是后来被称为“公平原则”（Fairness Doctrine）的基础。所以那是50和60年代，那些电台正在切断NBC对民权运动的报道。
And it's not just morally dubious. It's actually against the policies of the FCC. Exactly, right. So civil rights activists decided to put that to the test, and they ended up challenging WLBT's license for repeatedly denying them air time. At first, the FCC dismissed the case, but then the activists sued the FCC, and they won. And eventually, years later, a federal court decided that WLBT could stay on the air, but their license would be transferred to a nonprofit, multi-racial group of broadcasters.
这不仅在道德上令人怀疑，实际上还违反了FCC的政策。完全正确。因此，民权活动人士决定对此进行测试，他们最终挑战了WLBT的执照，理由是该电台多次拒绝给予他们播出时间。起初，FCC驳回了此案，但随后活动人士起诉了FCC，他们赢了。最终，几年后，联邦法院裁定WLBT可以继续播出，但其执照将被转让给一个非营利性的、多种族的广播机构。
Wow, that's huge. Yeah. So this case ended up having impact beyond this station, right? Like obviously, the problem of racist one-sided coverage went beyond just WLBT. Right. And this case actually had enormous repercussions for the radio and TV industries. They were both overseen by the FCC. And there were a few really big things that this case did over the course of its many
哇，这太重大了。是的。所以这个案件的影响力超出了这家电台，对吧？显然，种族主义的单方面报道问题不仅仅存在于WLBT。没错。这个案件实际上对广播和电视行业产生了巨大的影响。它们都由FCC监管。在这个案件漫长的
year back and forth. First of all, just by accepting the case, the court set a really important precedent. The ruling gave local communities the power to challenge licenses, radio and television licenses across the country. So for the first time, people, common citizens could legally and successfully challenge licenses if they thought a broadcaster wasn't following the FCC's rules, like serving the public interest and being fair. So it wasn't just the FCC like looking for violators
来回过程中，它做了几件非常重大的事情。首先，法院仅仅通过受理此案，就确立了一个非常重要的先例。该裁决赋予了当地社区挑战全国广播和电视执照的权力。因此，普通公民第一次可以在认为广播公司没有遵守FCC规则（如服务于公共利益和保持公平）时，合法且成功地挑战其执照。所以不仅仅是FCC在寻找违规者
and then therefore like challenging licenses. People actually took the power in their own hands to challenge licenses around the country. Yeah, yes, exactly. People could write to stations, saying they weren't being balanced in their coverage and asking for air time for certain issues. And now all of a sudden, the station actually felt pressure
并因此挑战执照。人们实际上掌握了权力，开始在全国范围内挑战执照。是的，完全正确。人们可以写信给电台，指出他们的报道不平衡，并要求就某些议题获得播出时间。现在，电台突然感受到了压力，
to listen to them. Huh, and I'm assuming this makes broadcasters really nervous, especially the gross ones that are antisoable rights. Yes, it does, and that brings us to some of the other industry changing things that the WLBT case did, as it was going through the courts, and especially after it was decided that the license would be transferred, broadcasters were worried about their licenses getting called in the question. So the FCC starts giving broadcasters recommendations
不得不倾听他们的声音。嗯，我猜这会让广播公司非常紧张，尤其是那些反民权的顽固分子。是的，确实如此，这引出了WLBT案件带来的其他改变行业的事情。随着案件在法院审理，特别是在决定执照将被转让后，广播公司开始担心他们的执照会被收回。因此，FCC开始向广播公司提供建议，
of how they can avoid that same fate, how they can satisfy that longstanding vague requirement to serve the public interest. And they really start pushing this thing called ascertainment. Asher attainments were when people in local communities were interviewed by station officials, people who were never asked before,
告诉他们如何避免同样的命运，如何满足那个长期以来模糊的“服务于公共利益”的要求。他们真的开始推行一种叫做“确定性调查”（ascertainment）的东西。确定性调查是指电台官员采访当地社区的人们，那些以前从未被问过的人，
what do you think ought to be on radio? What do you think ought to be on TV? Now they were being asked these questions. This was done by radio stations and television stations, commercial stations, public stations across the country. You know, this seems so simple and so revolutionary at the same time. Like, just ask people they want to hear about and maybe that would shape the broadcasting accordingly. Yeah, yeah, it was pretty revolutionary. Like, people who worked in radio and TV, which we're
“你认为广播里应该播什么？你认为电视里应该播什么？”现在他们被问到了这些问题。全国各地的广播电台、电视台、商业电台和公共电台都这样做。你知道，这看起来既简单又具有革命性。就像，只要问问人们想听什么，也许这就会相应地塑造广播内容。是的，是的，这确实相当具有革命性。就像在广播和电视工作的人，我们
both overseen by the FCC, were literally going into church basements and women shelters and asking about the issues that people wanted to be covered. But in a handful of years, the FCC would actually come to require this process. And they would also come to more or less require that all stations, even stations that played mostly music, which was a lot of stations,
都由FCC监管，他们真的走进教堂地下室和妇女收容所，询问人们希望报道的问题。但在几年内，FCC实际上开始要求执行这一程序。他们还或多或少地要求所有电台，即使是那些主要播放音乐的电台（这占了很大一部分），
run some small amount of educational programming. So as all of this was shaping up in the late 60s and the early 70s, the radio was changing because people had a say now. The stations began to understand that if they did not begin to follow these guidelines, if they didn't follow the Theronis doctrine, if they didn't do these ascertainment reports,
也要运行一些少量的教育节目。因此，当这一切在60年代末和70年代初成形时，广播正在发生变化，因为人们现在有了发言权。电台开始明白，如果他们不开始遵守这些准则，如果他们不遵守“公平原则”，如果他们不做这些确定性调查报告，
then local communities would challenge their licenses. People did challenge broadcast licenses, but often the threat alone was enough to get stations to pay attention. As the 1960s bore on, the civil rights movement started getting more on air coverage on radio and TV. And when people started hearing
那么当地社区就会挑战他们的执照。人们确实挑战了广播执照，但往往仅凭威胁就足以让电台引起重视。随着60年代的推进，民权运动开始在广播和电视上获得更多报道。当人们开始听到
and seeing civil rights activists getting attacked by police dogs and brutally harassed by white residents, it helped increase support for the movement. Right. I mean, the fairness doctrine works when you hear perspectives, multiple perspectives. You actually burn and change. Yeah, like media exposure.
并看到民权活动人士被警犬攻击、被白人居民残酷骚扰时，这有助于增加对运动的支持。没错。我的意思是，当你听到多种观点时，“公平原则”是有效的。你实际上会改变。是的，就像媒体曝光一样。
That's a good thing to know. It's helpful. And coming into the 1970s now, people continue to use the airwaves to talk about all sorts of political and cultural issues that were important to them. So my black brothers in the United States of America, I say it's in place, as you are dilemma, as a historically sensitive people is the same as mine. You could turn on the radio and hear a broadcast about black history or indigenous solidarity.
这是一个很好的知识点。很有帮助。进入70年代，人们继续利用电波讨论各种对他们重要的政治和文化议题。所以，我的美国黑人兄弟们，我说它就在那里，作为历史上敏感的群体，你们的困境和我的是一样的。你可以打开收音机，听到关于黑人历史或原住民团结的广播。
This is John Ferdellan inviting you to Indian land radio, Indian land alcatraz island. Realizing that I was gay and funny. There were gay and lesbian shows, shows about agriculture. I raised about 88 years of porn. Whatever potential listeners said was important to them. This was the time when we really began to see news and public affairs programs become really important in the American culture. This is getting through radio I really like. And it really represents a really big shift. Oh yeah, I mean, this is a really big moment. All of these changes result in what Mark calls broadcastings public interest moment where he says there was an explosion
这是约翰·弗德兰邀请你收听“印第安土地广播”，印第安土地恶魔岛。意识到我是同性恋，这很有趣。有同性恋节目，有关于农业的节目。我筹集了大约88年的……无论潜在听众说什么是重要的。这是我们真正开始看到新闻和公共事务节目在美国文化中变得非常重要的时期。这是我真正喜欢的广播。它确实代表了一个非常大的转变。噢，是的，我的意思是，这是一个非常重要的时刻。所有这些变化导致了马克所说的广播的“公共利益时刻”，他说当时出现了
of news shows and Sunday morning public affairs shows on radio and TV. This is the era that public broadcasting first got serious federal support between the late 60s and the late 70s shows like 60 minutes start up. Good evening. This is 60 minutes. It's a kind of a magazine for television, which means it has the flexibility
新闻节目和周日早间公共事务节目的爆发。这是公共广播首次获得严肃联邦支持的时代，在60年代末到70年代末之间，像《60分钟》这样的节目开始了。晚上好。这是《60分钟》。它是一种电视杂志，这意味着它具有
and diversity of a magazine adapted to broadcast journalism. I mean, this sounds so much like somebody trying to describe their podcast, you know, like it's so different. Things aren't so different. Totally. But, you know, this was really like a different moment, a changing moment for broadcasters, because newsrooms start to become ever so slightly more integrated. In just a few years, the radio dial and TV band had become much more representative
杂志的灵活性和多样性，并适应了广播新闻。我的意思是，这听起来太像有人在试图描述他们的播客了，你知道，这太不同了。事情并没有那么不同。完全正确。但是，你知道，这确实是一个不同的时刻，一个对广播公司来说正在改变的时刻，因为新闻编辑室开始变得稍微更加融合。在短短几年内，广播和电视波段变得更加具有
of all that America was. And I wanna say, conservative voices had long found a pretty solid platform on radio. They were ultimately part of the status quo that many civil rights leaders were pushing against when they took on media reform. But conservative voices are part of this public interest moment too. You saw right wing watchdogs using the fairness doctrine to get a bunch of air time to respond
美国社会的代表性。我想说，保守派的声音长期以来在广播中找到了一个相当稳固的平台。他们最终是许多民权领袖在进行媒体改革时所反对的现状的一部分。但保守派的声音也是这个“公共利益时刻”的一部分。你看到了右翼监督机构利用“公平原则”获得了大量的播出时间，以回应
to critical news coverage with pro-Nixon content. So this legal battle that started with civil rights leaders ends up providing all sorts of people with tools to increase speech on the air, even folks who might have previously fought against civil rights. Yeah, even folks who might have previously fought against civil rights. Yeah, even them. So conservative voices were definitely on the air, but it was far from the one-sidedness you're liable to hear today. And so why is it the way it is today?
对尼克松有利的内容来反击批评性的新闻报道。所以，这场始于民权领袖的法律斗争，最终为各种各样的人提供了增加电波言论的工具，即使是那些以前可能反对民权的人。是的，即使是那些以前可能反对民权的人。是的，甚至包括他们。所以保守派的声音确实在电波上，但它远非你今天可能听到的那种单方面。那么为什么今天会变成这样呢？
You know, like if it was this mess of, you know, conservative voices and new liberal voices and civil rights and even anti-civil rights, Like, how do we get to the point where one person can talk for two hours with just sort of misinformation and, you know, right wings, not time. Right, right, and two hours like every day across the state of the coastal country. Right, well, before we get there, and which we will get there,
你知道，如果当时是一团糟，你知道，保守派声音、新自由派声音、民权运动，甚至反民权运动，我们是怎么走到一个人可以谈论两个小时，只充斥着某种错误信息和，你知道，右翼，不是时间。对，对，而且每天两个小时，横跨整个沿海国家。对，好吧，在我们到达那里之前，我们确实会到达那里，
let me tell you about one other thing that was turning the radio world on its head in the 1970s. And here's a brand new Deluxe AMFM model, thing that was turning the radio world on its head in the 1970s. And here's a brand new Deluxe AMFM model, the XF4 Emissary. The difference in reception will leap to the ear. So all of these legal changes coincided with the explosion of FM radio, which overtook AM and listenership in the late 1970s. And what is the significance of FM,
让我告诉你另一件在70年代颠覆广播世界的事情。这是一个全新的豪华AM/FM型号，XF4特使。接收效果的差异会让你耳目一新。所以所有这些法律变化都与FM广播的爆发相吻合，FM在70年代末超过了AM的收听率。那么FM的意义是什么，
for the purposes of this conversation? Basically with AM or amplitude modulation radio, the signal was super buzzy. There's always a sort of ambient hum, like you know what I mean? It's like, hmm, constantly. Yeah, totally. It's a little annoying.
为了这次谈话的目的？基本上，对于AM或调幅广播，信号非常嘈杂。总有一种环境嗡嗡声，你知道我的意思吗？就像，嗯，持续不断。是的，完全是。这有点烦人。
It's kind of like looking through a dirty window, but then with FM, sound was encoded into radio signals differently, and it was super clean. Like compared to the muck of AM, it was like freshly shined glass. So, if you really want high quality, which is like music, you move that over to FM. Yeah, absolutely. That's exactly what happened. Music stations rush over to FM. And so for a while, the AM band is kind of floundering. Like AM needs a unique selling point. Yeah, and that selling point is talk radio, you know? That's what they can do well.
这有点像透过脏窗户看东西，但有了FM，声音被以不同的方式编码到无线电信号中，而且非常干净。就像与AM的泥泞相比，它就像刚擦亮的玻璃。所以，如果你真的想要高质量，比如音乐，你就把它转到FM。是的，绝对是。这正是发生的事情。音乐电台涌向FM。所以有一段时间，AM波段有点挣扎。就像AM需要一个独特的卖点。是的，而那个卖点就是谈话广播，你知道吗？那是他们能做好的事情。
Exactly, exactly. You don't need high fidelity sound. You just talk. So talk radio is pretty much AM salvation. And that's especially true once this new revolutionary high-tech format entered the scene and That's the Colin show Hello, yes, Bob have a problem. What should I do?
完全正确，完全正确。你不需要高保真声音。你只需要说话。所以谈话广播几乎是AM的救星。一旦这种新的革命性高科技格式进入现场，情况尤其如此。那是科林秀，你好，是的，鲍勃有个问题。我该怎么办？
Okay, so talk to me about Colin chose because I mean these is just the foundation of radio broadcasting talk to me about Colin Chose because I mean, these are just the foundation of radio broadcasting. Talk to me about how those affected everything. Totally. I mean, now it's just like quintessential radio, basically, almost sort of kitschy, but at the time, like the seamless Colin show or more or less seamless, I should say, was pretty new. The idea that somebody can hear themselves on the radio by calling in
好的，那么跟我谈谈科林秀，因为我的意思是，这些只是广播谈话节目的基础。跟我谈谈这些是如何影响一切的。完全正确。我的意思是，现在这就像典型的广播，基本上，有点俗气，但在当时，像无缝的科林秀，或者我应该说或多或少是无缝的，是相当新的。有人可以通过打电话
and talking to the host. And I sound so old school at this point, but it really was a revolution. This is Nicole Hemmer. She's an author and scholar of media and conservative movements. And she says this really was a big deal, like to be able to be part of the media. There had been some call-in shows in the past, like as early as the 1920s, but basically the host would answer the phone and either hold the receiver up to the microphone or they'd just take the call privately with a live mic and say, mm-hmm.
并与主持人交谈，在广播中听到自己的声音。这在这一点上听起来太老派了，但这确实是一场革命。这是妮可·海默。她是媒体和保守运动的作家和学者。她说这确实是一件大事，就像能够成为媒体的一部分一样。过去曾有一些电话节目，早在20世纪20年代，但基本上主持人会接听电话，要么把听筒举到麦克风前，要么他们只是私下接听电话，开着麦克风说，嗯哼。
Oh, okay, okay, listeners. So what the caller said. It was. It was like, high art. I totally agree. So Nicole Hemmer says that live national Collins shows, as we know and love them today, became possible because of two technological advances.
噢，好的，好的，听众们。所以打电话的人说了什么。这就像，高雅艺术。我完全同意。所以妮可·海默说，我们今天所知和喜爱的直播全国电话节目，之所以成为可能，是因为两项技术进步。
One, satellite dishes were becoming more and more accessible and affordable, meaning more stations could run a show simultaneously in two different cities for cheaper. And around the same time, there were some changes in long distance telephone technology, and the cost of the calls went way down. And once you have those two things where I can make a toll-free call
第一，卫星天线变得越来越普及和负担得起，这意味着更多的电台可以以更低的成本在两个不同的城市同时播放一个节目。与此同时，长途电话技术发生了一些变化，通话成本大幅下降。一旦你有了这两样东西，我可以拨打免费电话
to a show that is being aired around the nation all at the same time, so that people in Oregon and people in New York can listen to the same station, can be listening to the same content at the same time, can be calling in at the same time. Now you can have a national conversation on radio. Our phone lines are now open on the Larry King show. From all time zones, the number to call is 703-685-2177.
到一个在全国各地同时播出的节目，这样俄勒冈州的人和纽约州的人可以收听同一个电台，可以在同一时间收听相同的内容，可以在同一时间打电话进来。现在你可以在广播上进行全国性的对话了。我们的电话线现在在拉里·金秀上开通了。从所有时区，拨打的号码是703-685-2177。
Thank you very much, Fred Larry, our special guest. And it changes the medium because it makes it more interactive. And it makes people feel invested in shows because even if they don't call in, they hear people like themselves calling in. And they feel like they're being represented on this new talk radio. Yeah, I can see why this is just a huge change because before this, you know, people just consumed media. They did not partake in it. They didn't have the internet.
非常感谢，弗雷德·拉里，我们的特别嘉宾。它改变了媒介，因为它使它更具互动性。它让人们感到对节目有投入感，因为即使他们不打电话进来，他们也会听到像他们一样的人打电话进来。他们觉得他们在这个新的谈话广播中得到了代表。是的，我能看出为什么这是一个巨大的变化，因为在此之前，你知道，人们只是消费媒体。他们不参与其中。他们没有互联网。
It was just this was the first time people could hear themselves. Totally. Yeah, the Colin model was kind of astonishingly democratic for the time. So there's FM and AM and Colin shows and there are these policies that are getting more diverse viewpoints on the air.
这是人们第一次能听到自己的声音。完全正确。是的，科林模式在当时是相当令人惊讶的民主。所以有FM和AM和科林秀，还有这些政策让更多样化的观点出现在电波上。
Yeah. So how does this slide us into all conservative all the time? Well, Roman. The Reagan administration came in and then began to eliminate all of those regulations. Reagan came in, all of it was gone. Yeah, it always starts with Reagan. Yep.
是的。那么这怎么让我们滑向“全保守派，一直保守”呢？嗯，罗曼。里根政府上台，然后开始消除所有这些法规。里根上台，一切都没了。是的，总是从里根开始。是的。
Go figure. As is often the case, Reagan is the plot's pivot point. So Reagan comes in in 1980, after a decade or so of pretty exciting changes in media. So what exactly did the Reagan administration do? Well, basically, not long after the president took office, Reagan's FCC started killing off all of the policies and guidelines that had been built up during the civil rights era. The FCC made some major changes in how radio stations are run.
想一想。正如通常情况一样，里根是情节的转折点。所以里根在1980年上台，在经历了大约十年的媒体相当令人兴奋的变化之后。那么里根政府到底做了什么？嗯，基本上，总统上任后不久，里根的FCC就开始废除所有在民权时代建立起来的政策和准则。FCC在广播电台的运营方式上做了一些重大改变。
No more requirements to go out and see what local residents want to hear. No more mandate to run some educational shows. There are no longer limits on the number of commercials a station may play. The FCC also made it harder for people to challenge broadcast licenses. The fairness doctrine was still alive, but without these other policies, it was losing its teeth. The free market will now determine what a station plays. During this era, the number of complaints to the FCC about racial stereotyping and a lack
不再要求去了解当地居民想听什么。不再强制播放一些教育节目。电台可以播放的广告数量不再有限制。FCC还使人们更难挑战广播执照。“公平原则”仍然存在，但没有了这些其他政策，它正在失去效力。自由市场现在将决定电台播放什么。在这一时期，向FCC投诉种族定型和缺乏
of programming from minority groups both went up. But with public interest guidelines removed or defanged, people just didn't have much recourse. Hmm. So people, like every day people didn't have nearly as much say in what was on the radio anymore. Yeah, exactly. And coinciding with this decline of public influence, was the rise of a new breed of talk show host.
少数群体节目的数量都上升了。但随着公共利益准则被移除或削弱，人们确实没有太多追索权。嗯。所以人们，像普通人，在广播里播什么方面不再有那么大的发言权了。是的，完全正确。与这种公众影响力的下降相吻合的，是新一代谈话节目主持人的崛起。
Early in the morning, when most of us are still sleeping, there's a madman loose on the bolder, more Washington airwaves, and anyone with a phone and a thick skin is invited to join in the madness. After the break, the dawn of the American Shock-Dock. The New York Times The New York Times All right, so after years of this public interest agenda being an animating principle within the FCC, Reagan got into office and basically deregulated the living hell out of broadcasting. And this coincided with the rise of a new
清晨，当我们大多数人还在睡觉时，在更大、更华盛顿的电波上有一个疯子，任何有电话和厚脸皮的人都被邀请加入这场疯狂。休息之后，美国“冲击电台”（Shock-Jock）的黎明。《纽约时报》《纽约时报》好的，所以在这种公共利益议程作为FCC内部激励原则多年之后，里根上台，基本上对广播进行了彻底的去监管。这与一种新的
Loud provocative type of radio host. That's right. This was the era of the shock jock Basically, brash offensive high-energy disc jockey So this is Howard Stern yes So this is Howard Stern. Yes. The all-hale Howard Stern of serious activity. Yes, that is correct. So this is Howard Stern pioneering Shock Jack King. I mean, but Stern, especially when he started,
大声、挑衅的广播主持人类型的崛起相吻合。没错。这是“冲击电台”时代。基本上，粗鲁、冒犯、高能量的唱片骑师。所以这是霍华德·斯特恩。是的。所以这是霍华德·斯特恩。是的。万岁，霍华德·斯特恩，严肃活动。是的，那是正确的。所以这是霍华德·斯特恩开创的冲击电台之王。我的意思是，但斯特恩，尤其是当他开始时，
wasn't especially political. I mean, he's become politicized over the years, but he wasn't like a political talk show host. He was just trying to get people's attention. Right, exactly. Just shocking people. Shockjogs were rarely political, exactly. Just shocking people. Shockjogs were rarely political,
并不是特别政治化。我的意思是，他多年来变得政治化了，但他不是那种政治谈话节目主持人。他只是想引起人们的注意。对，完全正确。只是震惊人们。冲击电台主持人很少是政治性的，完全正确。只是震惊人们。冲击电台主持人很少是政治性的，
especially in the early days. They were mostly just kind of like, lute or gross, shocking, you know, as is in the name. But as that sort of brash-new style got popular, it became clear that political talk could bring that shock-jog energy to. My dear, anybody with program like you is per celebration.
尤其是在早期。他们大多只是有点，淫秽或粗俗，令人震惊，你知道，正如名字所暗示的那样。但随着那种粗鲁的新风格流行起来，很明显政治谈话也能带来那种冲击电台的能量。亲爱的，任何有像你这样节目的人都是庆祝。
I'm glad I'm going to Printer better. You are you are Committable. Goodbye. 7 6 1. This is Alan Berg. He was a Liberal Talk radio host out of Denver. He got started in the late 1970s and was really taking off in the early 80s. He was Jewish and was known for being pretty vitriolic and calling out racism and bigotry. Somebody can you are not see by your very own vision. That's so much. It's because that's right.
我很高兴我要打印得更好。你是，你是可承诺的。再见。7 6 1。这是艾伦·伯格。他是丹佛的一位自由派谈话广播主持人。他在70年代末开始，在80年代初真正起飞。他是犹太人，以尖刻和呼吁反对种族主义和偏见而闻名。有人可以，你不是通过你自己的愿景看到的。那太多了。这是因为那是对的。
You heard it. Okay. 8-6-1-2-8-6-1-8-2-5. Given what we know about AM and FM talk radio, now this is very surprising to hear. I mean, it's got the in your face, confrontational talk show vibe, but it's from the opposite side
你听到了。好的。8-6-1-2-8-6-1-8-2-5。鉴于我们对AM和FM谈话广播的了解，现在听到这个非常令人惊讶。我的意思是，它有那种面对面、对抗性的谈话节目氛围，但它来自政治光谱的对立面。
of the political spectrum. Totally. It is surprising. And to paint a picture of how he was received, at one point, there's this poll that goes out in Denver that asks residents to name the city's most beloved media personality and it's most despised. And Ellen Berg won both awards. That's a feat.
完全正确。这令人惊讶。为了描绘他是如何被接受的，有一次，丹佛进行了一项民意调查，要求居民说出该市最受喜爱的媒体人物和最受鄙视的媒体人物。艾伦·伯格赢得了这两个奖项。那是一个壮举。
That's kind of incredible. And Ellen Berg was super well known. I mean, he was on a huge station. His show could be heard in about 30 different states. But obviously not everyone used their radio platform to call out racism and bigotry. That is true. And a heads up that this next section
这简直不可思议。而且艾伦·伯格非常出名。我的意思是，他在一个巨大的电台上。他的节目可以在大约30个不同的州听到。但显然不是每个人都利用他们的广播平台来呼吁反对种族主义和偏见。这是真的。提醒一下，接下来的部分
is going to include some really hateful talk radio. Let me put it to you, this way. The NFL all too often looks like a game between the bloods and the crypts without any weapons. Okay, here he is. This is Rush Limbaugh. Yes. Before the uninitiated Rush Limbaugh is known for these racist diatrives and also for calling
将包含一些非常仇恨的谈话广播。让我这样告诉你。NFL太频繁地看起来像是一场血帮和瘸帮之间没有武器的游戏。好的，他在这里。这是拉什·林博。是的。对于外行来说，拉什·林博以这些种族主义的长篇大论而闻名，也因为称
feminists, feminazes and for some incredibly homophobic recurring segments for vilifying the poor, you name it, he probably said it. And not to say the obvious, but this is very different from what Alan Berg was doing. Yeah, a lot of people have referred to Alan Berg as a sort of limbaugh of the left. And it's true, you know, their styles were similar. I mean, their styles may have been similar, but Berg was calling out racism and limbaugh was literally just spreading racism. Yeah, exactly. It's actually really interesting to look at Limbaugh's trajectory
女权主义者为“女权纳粹”，以及一些令人难以置信的恐同循环片段，因为诋毁穷人，你能想到的，他可能都说过。不用说显而易见的事情，但这与艾伦·伯格所做的事情非常不同。是的，很多人把艾伦·伯格称为某种左翼的林博。这是真的，你知道，他们的风格很相似。我的意思是，他们的风格可能很相似，但伯格是在呼吁反对种族主义，而林博实际上只是在传播种族主义。是的，完全正确。观察林博的轨迹其实非常有趣，
because I think it kind of tells a story in itself. Limbaugh had always been a radio guy, but not always the most successful one. Over almost two decades in radio, he was fired as a DJ from six stations. But during these years working on and off behind a mic, he noticed something. When he talked about politics, which wasn't something he really cared about in his early years,
因为我认为它本身就讲述了一个故事。林博一直是个广播人，但并不总是最成功的一个。在广播界的近二十年里，他作为DJ被六个电台解雇。但在这些断断续续在麦克风后工作的岁月里，他注意到了一些事情。当他谈论政治时，这并不是他在早年真正关心的事情，
the phones lit up. This was the 1970s and into the 1980s, right as America was experiencing the start of a conservative wave, fueled largely by backlash to the civil rights movement and the rise of the religious right, and Rush rode that wave all the way to the civil rights movement and the rise of the religious right. And Rush rode that wave all the way to the host chair. In 1984, a radio station in Sacramento took a chance on Rush and gave him his own show. And this is where he really found his sound. Yes, and well, I really don't feel like we need to give Limbaugh much airtime.
电话就响个不停。这是70年代到80年代，就在美国经历保守浪潮开始的时候，这在很大程度上是由对民权运动的反弹和宗教右翼的崛起所推动的，而拉什一路乘着那股浪潮到达了主持人席位。1984年，萨克拉门托的一家广播电台冒险录用了拉什，并给了他自己的节目。这就是他真正找到自己声音的地方。是的，而且，我真的不觉得我们需要给林博太多的播出时间。
He had a lot of it in his life. I do think it's important to hear just a bit more of what this sounded like, because you can hear a lot of similarities to present-day talk radio in everything from the conversational if totally hostile tone down to the really biting and just a warrant and false commentary. How many of you guys, your own experience experience with women have learned that no means yes if you know how to spot it. This is hard to listen to. Yeah, it's really hard to listen to. But, you know, Russia's political and cultural rants made films ring off the hook, ratings soared, and that meant more advertisers. And Limba from the beginning was not shy to admit
他在他的一生中已经有很多了。我确实认为听听这听起来是什么样子的很重要，因为你可以在一切中听到与当今谈话广播的许多相似之处，从对话的（如果完全敌对的）语气，到非常尖刻和完全不公正和虚假的评论。你们有多少人，你们自己在与女性的经历中了解到，如果你知道如何发现它，不就是是的意思。这很难听。是的，这真的很难听。但是，你知道，拉什的政治和文化咆哮让电话响个不停，收视率飙升，这意味着更多的广告商。而林博从一开始就不羞于承认
that he was in it first and foremost for money. So he did more of what sold. So we've got Limbaugh from the beginning was not shy to admit that he was in it first and foremost for money, so he did more of what sold. So we've got Limbaugh and Berg as pretty much polar opposites using a similar style to reach listeners. Yeah, and you can imagine a world where these two fast-talking in your face hosts are duking it out and fighting about politics over the public airwaves, but in 1984, the same year, Limbaw got his start out West. 50-year-old Alan Berg was murdered in his driveway. And I'm going to play you some tape from Berg's home station, K-O-A, from the night of his murder.
他首先是为了钱。所以他做了更多卖得好的事情。所以我们有林博从一开始就不羞于承认他首先是为了钱，所以他做了更多卖得好的事情。所以我们有林博和伯格作为几乎完全相反的人，使用相似的风格来接触听众。是的，你可以想象一个世界，这两个快嘴、面对面的主持人正在争斗，并在公共电波上为政治而战，但在1984年，也就是林博在西部开始的那一年，50岁的艾伦·伯格在他的车道上被谋杀。我要播放一些伯格所在电台KOA在他被谋杀那晚的录音。
It's from his friend and fellow K-O-A host, Ken Hamlin. It honestly still gets me really choked up, even though I've heard it now dozens of times. 1039 KOA time and we're still trying to piece information together. Off the air I'm finding out that someone passing in a vehicle using a semi-automatic weapon or an automatic weapon I'm not sure which fired upon Alan Berg when he was exiting his vehicle in front of his home. To describe how I feel right now, I've got a high-pitched ringing sound in my ears. My head is throbbing, and I can't believe it.
这是来自他的朋友和KOA同事肯·哈姆林。老实说，这仍然让我非常哽咽，即使我已经听过几十次了。1039 KOA时间，我们仍在试图拼凑信息。在广播外，我发现有人在车辆中通过半自动武器或自动武器（我不确定是哪一种）在艾伦·伯格离开车辆在他家门前时向他开火。要描述我现在感觉如何，我的耳朵里有一种高音的耳鸣声。我的头在跳动，我无法相信。
Berg was killed by members of a newly formed white supremacist group called the Order, founded by a man named David Lane, who drove the getaway car from the scene of Berg's murder. And remember that caller we heard earlier, the one who Alan Berg called a Nazi by his own admission? Yeah. That caller was David Lane. Oh my God. Oh my God. I, oh, so he was like a regular listener and called into the show. Yeah, yeah, he listened, called, talk to Alan Berg and proceeded to organize his murder. And Lane died in prison in 2007.
伯格被一个新成立的名为“秩序”（The Order）的白人至上主义团体的成员杀害，该团体由一个名叫大卫·莱恩的人创立，他驾驶了伯格谋杀现场的逃跑车辆。还记得我们之前听到的那个打电话的人吗，那个艾伦·伯格称他为纳粹的人？是的。那个打电话的人就是大卫·莱恩。天哪。天哪。我，噢，所以他就像一个经常收听并打电话到节目的人。是的，是的，他听了，打了电话，和艾伦·伯格交谈，并着手组织了他的谋杀。莱恩于2007年在监狱中去世。
And he remains a really influential figure in the white supremacist movement of today. I tell you, we used to sit down at lunch. White supremacist movement of today. I tell you, we used to sit down at lunch. Now, Illinois was used to say they're out there, but you can't worry about them. They're out there. You can't worry about them, you.
他仍然是当今白人至上主义运动中一个非常有影响力的人物。我告诉你，我们过去常坐下来吃午饭。当今白人至上主义运动。我告诉你，我们过去常坐下来吃午饭。现在，伊利诺伊州过去常说他们在外面，但你不能担心他们。他们在外面。你不能担心他们，你。
You never know, you know? You never know where the nuts are going to come from is what he used to say. So you live from day to day. It's just so sad. Yeah, it's really hard to listen to. So at this time, this style of rash political talk, it's game steam, and the left just lost one of its most prominent, up-and- upcoming voices to White supremacist violence. That's right.
你永远不知道，对吧？他过去常说，你永远不知道坚果会从哪里冒出来。所以你只能过一天算一天。这真是太令人难过了。是的，听起来确实很难受。所以在这个时候，这种激进的政治言论风格，简直是如日中天，而左派刚刚因为白人至上主义的暴力失去了一位最杰出、最有前途的代言人。没错。
And just a few years after that, came a change in the national radio landscape that allowed provocative political talk to reach whole new heights. This week, the FCC voted down the fairness doctrine by a vote of 4-0. What do you think this is going to mean for the average consumer of news and information? Various pendants think that eventually it will cut off minority viewpoints that have been using the doctrine to get heard. The fairness doctrine was that piece of policy that required stations to present multiple perspectives on coverage of controversial issues. This is like the cornerstone of why
在那之后仅仅几年，全国广播格局发生了变化，使得挑衅性的政治谈话达到了全新的高度。本周，联邦通信委员会（FCC）以4比0的投票结果否决了“公平原则”。你认为这对普通的新闻和信息消费者意味着什么？各种专家认为，这最终会切断那些一直利用该原则来争取发声机会的少数群体的观点。“公平原则”是一项要求电台在报道争议性议题时必须呈现多种观点的政策。这就像是为什么
there were multiple voices on the air. Yeah, that's right. In practice, the fairness doctrine had already been weakened when other public interest guidelines went out the window. But this was its formal death blow. And so what was Reagan's and the FCC's basis for getting rid of the fairness doctrine, besides just, you know, a love affair with getting rid of all government regulations? Yeah, basically, the fairness doctrine was built in part on that idea that there weren't enough channels or radio frequencies for everyone who wanted to broadcast to get on
广播中会有多种声音的基石。是的，没错。实际上，当其他公共利益准则被废除时，“公平原则”就已经被削弱了。但这却是它的正式致命一击。那么，除了对废除所有政府监管的热衷之外，里根政府和FCC废除“公平原则”的依据是什么？是的，基本上，“公平原则”的建立部分基于这样一种观点，即对于所有想要广播的人来说，没有足够的频道或无线电频率供大家使用
the airwaves. So having one of those stations was considered a privilege. And part of what you had to do in exchange for that privilege, they had said, was to present multiple perspectives. But Reagan's FCC points to a new thing called cable television to say that that scarcity argument isn't really relevant anymore. So the idea was that with cable, there are now tons and tons of channels. So if you don't get airtime on one station,
广播。因此，拥有其中一个电台被认为是一种特权。他们说，作为交换这种特权的一部分，你必须呈现多种观点。但里根的FCC指出了一个叫有线电视的新事物，以此说明那种稀缺性论点已经不再适用了。所以他们的想法是，有了有线电视，现在有成千上万个频道。所以如果你在一个电台上得不到播出时间，
you can just go to a different one, or you can just make your own. Right, yeah, that's the idea, but there are some flaws with that argument. First, not everyone had cable. Also, you can't watch cable while you're a community to work or working on a job site. Plenty of people still relied on radio, not television
你可以去另一个电台，或者你可以自己做一个。对，没错，这就是他们的想法，但这个论点有一些缺陷。首先，并不是每个人都有有线电视。此外，你不能在通勤上班或在工地工作时看有线电视。很多人仍然依赖广播，而不是电视
for their news, which is still the case today. Yeah. And also, the existence of cable TV doesn't mean there's suddenly more radio frequencies available. Right, exactly. Like, that's another huge flaw in the argument. So, describe to me what happens after the fairness doctrine dies. Yeah, well, highly political, often vitriolic talk radio without any counterpoints skyrocketed
来获取新闻，这种情况至今依然如此。是的。而且，有线电视的存在并不意味着突然有了更多的无线电频率可用。对，完全正确。这又是该论点的一个巨大缺陷。那么，请描述一下“公平原则”废除后发生了什么。是的，嗯，高度政治化、经常充满恶毒攻击且没有任何反驳观点的谈话广播激增，
and their breakout star was Rush Limbaugh. He talked about the fairness doctrine a lot on his show. He went into national syndication for the first time in 1988, which was the year after the fairness doctrine was eliminated. When lawmakers would try to reinstate the doctrine in the years that followed, a bunch of people on the right would call it the hush rush bill.
而他们最耀眼的明星是拉什·林博（Rush Limbaugh）。他在节目中经常谈论“公平原则”。1988年，也就是“公平原则”被废除后的第二年，他首次进入全国联合广播。在随后的几年里，当立法者试图恢复该原则时，右翼的一群人将其称为“禁声拉什法案”（Hush Rush bill）。
So for Limbaugh, the end of the fairness doctrine was a permission slip to kind of say whatever he wanted. And there was certainly an appetite for what he was saying. Rush gave voice to the grievances of a lot of people who were resistant to changes in culture and power. And Republican politicians understood that getting in good with Rush meant getting in good with his listeners.
所以对林博来说，“公平原则”的终结就像是一张可以随心所欲说话的通行证。而且人们对他的言论确实有需求。拉什为许多抵制文化和权力变革的人的怨气提供了出口。共和党政客们明白，与拉什搞好关系就意味着与他的听众搞好关系。
Yeah, yeah. I think I remember President George H. W. Bush literally carrying Rush's bags into the White House when he came for a visit. Right, right. That is the perfect image. Limbaugh had so much power over elected officials, and he inspired a lot of them, too, including this guy.
是的，是的。我记得乔治·H·W·布什总统在拉什来访时，甚至亲自帮他提包。对，对。那真是完美的写照。林博对民选官员拥有如此大的权力，他也激励了许多人，包括这个人。
In the 1990s, Russia inspired me to start a radio broadcast of my own. I used to say I was Russia Limbaugh on D-Calf. And for three hours a day on the airwaves of small town Indiana, I proceeded. And so that is Mike Pence. That is Mike Pence. Yep. D-Calf Limbaugh Mike Pence.
在20世纪90年代，拉什激励我开始了自己的广播节目。我过去常说我是“迪卡尔布（D-Calf）的拉什·林博”。在印第安纳州一个小镇的广播里，我每天进行三小时的节目。所以那是迈克·彭斯（Mike Pence）。那是迈克·彭斯。没错。迪卡尔布的林博，迈克·彭斯。
He was among the many talk hosts inspired by Limbaugh. And by 1995, about two thirdsthirds of political talk leaned right. I mean, two-thirds is a lot. It's already really significant, but like you mentioned earlier, now it's almost completely right wing talk radio and an often pretty far right too. Right, and there are a few other steps
他是受林博激励的众多谈话节目主持人之一。到1995年，大约三分之二的政治谈话节目倾向于右翼。我的意思是，三分之二是一个很大的比例。这已经非常显著了，但就像你之前提到的，现在几乎完全是右翼谈话广播，而且往往是非常极端的右翼。对，还有其他几个步骤
that helped us get there, including in 1996, something that really tightened the conservative grasp on the airwaves, President Clinton signed the Telecommunications Act into law. Among the many things the 96 Telecom acted was completely restructured the radio industry. There's a provision that goes into the bill that removes national ownership caps. So Roman, this is Brian Rosenwald, a media scholar who wrote a book about the limbaugh era of conservative talk radio.
帮助我们走到了这一步，包括1996年，一件真正加强了保守派对广播控制权的事情，克林顿总统签署了《电信法》。96年《电信法》所做的众多事情之一就是彻底重组了广播行业。法案中有一项条款取消了全国所有权上限。所以罗曼，这位是布莱恩·罗森瓦尔德（Brian Rosenwald），一位研究保守派谈话广播林博时代的媒体学者。
He says that basically since the 1940s, the government had limited the total number of radio stations that a single company could own, both in a single city and nationwide. Those ownership caps had been increasing for years under Reagan, but in 96, that national limit was completely removed. And that ends up triggering massive, massive, like, frenetic consolidation in the radio business in the late 90s, where companies are merging, companies are buying each other up. It basically becomes clear to most owners that you're not going to survive as like an individual owner.
他说，基本上自20世纪40年代以来，政府就限制了一家公司在单个城市和全国范围内可以拥有的电台总数。在里根执政期间，这些所有权上限多年来一直在增加，但在96年，全国性的限制被完全取消了。这最终引发了90年代末广播行业大规模、疯狂的整合，公司合并，公司互相收购。对大多数所有者来说，基本上变得很清楚，你作为个体所有者是无法生存的。
You either need to get big or get out. This led people who were already at an advantage in the market compound their power. For some perspective, the number of black owned stations was cut by more than half in the years between 1995 and 2012. The numbers have gone up a bit since then, but black Americans still own less than 2% of commercial radio stations in the country. And it wreaked havoc on local ownership too. Here's Mark Lloyd again.
你要么做大，要么出局。这导致那些在市场上已经处于优势地位的人进一步巩固了他们的权力。从某种角度来看，在1995年至2012年间，黑人拥有的电台数量减少了一半以上。从那以后数字有所上升，但美国黑人仍然只拥有全国不到2%的商业广播电台。这也对本地所有权造成了严重破坏。这是马克·劳埃德（Mark Lloyd）再次发言。
We ended up with an operation called Clear Channel that owned over 1200 radio stations, which was just unheard of during the public interest moment. The idea that any one entity could own 1200 stations. For reference, before 96, clear channel, now I Heart Media, own 43 stations. It took them less than a decade to get to over 1200. Oh my goodness. The 43 to 1200 stations, that's wild.
我们最终出现了一个叫“清晰频道”（Clear Channel）的运营机构，它拥有超过1200个广播电台，这在公共利益时代是闻所未闻的。任何一个实体竟然可以拥有1200个电台。作为参考，96年之前，清晰频道（现在的iHeartMedia）只拥有43个电台。他们用了不到十年时间就达到了1200多个。天哪。从43个到1200个电台，这太疯狂了。
I mean, you said this helped rush limba. How did this help Rush Limbaugh, in particular? Well, it helps a lot of big hosts and big radio companies, but I'll let Mark explain what it did for Limbaugh specifically. Well, Clear Channel owned Premiere Radio Networks, and guess who Premiere Radio Networks owned? They owned the Rush Limbaugh show. And guess what Clear Channel and the premier radio networks promoted and put on every station they could? Well, they put on the show that they owned, Rush Limbaugh. Of course they did. Yeah, and I should say Clear Channel bought premier
我的意思是，你说这帮助了拉什·林博。这对拉什·林博个人有什么帮助？嗯，它帮助了很多大牌主持人和大型广播公司，但我会让马克来解释它具体为林博做了什么。嗯，清晰频道拥有“首映广播网”（Premiere Radio Networks），你猜谁拥有首映广播网？他们拥有拉什·林博秀。你猜清晰频道和首映广播网推广并放在每一个他们能覆盖的电台上的节目是什么？嗯，他们放的是他们拥有的节目，拉什·林博秀。他们当然会这么做。是的，我应该说清晰频道在
in 1998. So Limbaugh found a lot of success before this, but this is an easy way to stay on top. And for other radio companies to point to his success and say, see, that's where we should be. So there was this burst of conservative talk host who took off in the early 2000s, Glen Beck, Sean Hannity, and consolidation was already pushing conservative talk radio to the right. So tell me about that, because deregulation
1998年收购了首映广播网。所以林博在此之前就取得了很大的成功，但这是一种保持领先地位的简单方法。其他广播公司也以他的成功为例说，看，这就是我们应该去的地方。因此，在21世纪初，出现了一批保守派谈话节目主持人，格伦·贝克（Glen Beck）、肖恩·汉尼提（Sean Hannity），而整合已经将保守派谈话广播推向了右翼。那么告诉我关于这一点，因为去监管化
consolidation, these are economic processes. They don't explicitly have to do with programming or programming tastes and what is popular. Yeah, so basically these big radio companies, like Clear Channel, vertically integrate. They own sometimes hundreds of stations, and rather than finding and paying hundreds of local hosts for time slots on those local stations,
整合，这些都是经济过程。它们并不明确与节目制作、节目品味以及什么受欢迎有关。是的，所以基本上这些大型广播公司，比如清晰频道，进行了垂直整合。他们有时拥有数百个电台，而不是在这些本地电台上寻找并支付数百名本地主持人的时段费用，
they can pump a bunch of money into one high profile host who show they can air everywhere. That still ends up being cheaper and easier than cultivating and hiring and getting advertisers to back a ton of individual local hosts all over the country. Consolidation and these big corporate ownerships create risk-adverse companies, risk-adverse executives, executives who want to program something that
他们可以将大量资金投入到一位高知名度的主持人身上，他们的节目可以在各地播出。这仍然比培养、雇佣并让广告商支持全国各地大量的个人本地主持人要便宜且容易得多。整合和这些大型企业所有权创造了厌恶风险的公司、厌恶风险的高管，这些高管想要制作一些
they know will work, and conservative talk is it. At the same time, a concept called format purity was trickling into talk radio from the music radio world. Basically, program directors started to think that one station should stick with one genre. That way, us Fussy listeners would know what to expect, and we tune in for longer, more TSL, time spent listening. And that would mean more advertising dollars. Radio executives think that there needs to be predictability.
他们知道会奏效的节目，而保守派谈话就是这样。与此同时，一个叫“格式纯度”的概念从音乐广播界渗透到了谈话广播中。基本上，节目总监开始认为一个电台应该坚持一种类型。这样，我们这些挑剔的听众就会知道会期待什么，我们收听的时间也会更长，即TSL（收听时间）。这意味着更多的广告收入。广播高管认为需要可预测性。
That if you turn on the conservative talk station, and there's a liberal guy on, you're like, well, did I turn the wrong station on? So most talk stations see what is working in many of their areas, and then they control more stations, and then they just very conservatively put that on there, and therefore the whole system is taken over just almost by force to represent one voice. Yeah, I mean, the limba model was seen as a good, safe business move.
如果你打开保守派谈话电台，却听到一个自由派的人在说话，你会想，我是不是调错电台了？所以大多数谈话电台看到在他们许多地区什么有效，然后他们控制更多的电台，然后他们就非常保守地把那个节目放上去，因此整个系统几乎是被强行接管，只代表一种声音。是的，我的意思是，林博模式被视为一种好的、安全的商业举措。
It's one decision upon one decision upon one decision that makes this make more and more and more sense. To the point that you get to the 2000s, and then they're like, okay, all conservative, all political, all nationally syndicated, or mostly nationally syndicated, that's how we make our money. So conservative talk, it comes to dominate. But does anyone on the left have to counter strike? Like, there's no reason why they couldn't work on the left have to sort of counter strike? Like, there's just, you know, there's no reason why they couldn't work on the left.
这是一个决定接着一个决定，让这一切变得越来越合理。直到21世纪，他们会说，好吧，全是保守派，全是政治，全是全国联合广播，或者大部分是全国联合广播，这就是我们赚钱的方式。所以保守派谈话占据了主导地位。但左派有人反击吗？就像，没有理由他们不能在左派工作，某种程度上反击？就像，你知道，没有理由他们不能在左派工作。
Yeah, you know, kind of. The big attempt to counter the rights hold on talk radio came when George W. Bush was running for re-election in 2004. Was a project called Air America? I remember as well. I was already in radio when Air America started. And this is like where, you know, Rachel Maddo really took off and in like, Chuck D from public Enemy was the host.
是的，你知道，算是吧。当乔治·W·布什在2004年竞选连任时，左派试图夺回谈话广播控制权的大尝试是一个叫“美国之音”（Air America）的项目。我也记得。当美国之音开始时，我已经在广播界工作了。这就是，你知道，蕾切尔·玛多（Rachel Maddow）真正起飞的地方，还有像“全民公敌”（Public Enemy）组合的查克·D（Chuck D）担任主持人。
And one of the hosts that I actually worked with at KLW in San Francisco left public radio to go work at Air America. So yeah, it was a big deal in that moment. Wow, yeah. But Air America had some problems from the start. A lot of hosts just didn't really have backgrounds in radio and like they didn't have great chemistry on their shows. And they also just didn't really have backgrounds in radio and like they didn't have great chemistry on their shows.
我实际上在旧金山的KLW电台共事过的一位主持人离开了公共广播，去美国之音工作。所以是的，在那一刻这是一件大事。哇，是的。但美国之音从一开始就有一些问题。很多主持人并没有广播背景，而且他们在节目中没有很好的化学反应。而且他们也确实没有广播背景，就像他们在节目中没有很好的化学反应一样。
And they also just didn't really do like a great job of speaking to listeners across the country. Just wasn't really great radio, I guess. But importantly, beyond just the content, Air America also suffered from the exact same system that was giving Rush Limba a boost. Remember, by this point, clear channel with over a thousand stations owned the company that owned the Rush Limba a boost. Remember, by this point, Clear Channel, with over a thousand stations, owned the company
而且他们也没有真正做好与全国听众交流的工作。我想那不是很好的广播。但重要的是，除了内容之外，美国之音也遭受了与给拉什·林博提供助力的完全相同的系统之苦。记住，到这个时候，拥有超过一千个电台的清晰频道拥有那家拥有拉什·林博秀的公司，记住，到这个时候，拥有超过一千个电台的清晰频道拥有
that owned the Rush Limba show? Air America didn't own any stations, so they had to convince existing stations to run their progressive talk shows. Which I imagine wasn't easy, with a lot of stations already airing conservative talk program from morning till night. Right. Air America went bankrupt in 2006 and we're totally off the air by 2010.
那家拥有拉什·林博秀的公司？美国之音没有任何电台，所以他们必须说服现有的电台播放他们的进步派谈话节目。我想这并不容易，因为很多电台已经从早到晚都在播放保守派谈话节目了。对。美国之音在2006年破产，到2010年完全停播。
It's worth noting that there were other individual cases where liberal talk show hosts had success in some markets, but in general, the big companies just didn't really run them. They could afford not to. And I can imagine, like as a liberal listener, you know, just hitting a wall of conservative talk when you try to AM radio, you just begin to not look for it anymore. And then there's this refuge inside of public radio, which gives you some nuanced and complex views and longer stories.
值得注意的是，还有其他个别案例，自由派谈话节目主持人在某些市场取得了成功，但总的来说，大公司并没有真正播放它们。他们负担得起不播放的代价。我可以想象，作为一个自由派听众，你知道，当你尝试AM广播时，撞上一堵保守派谈话的墙，你就会开始不再寻找它了。然后公共广播里有这样一个避难所，它给你提供一些细致入微、复杂的观点和更长的故事。
And therefore then things just stay the way they are because why would any liberal upstart, you know, find purchase in that landscape because I'm not looking for it. And I've given up so long ago that it doesn't really matter. Yeah, definitely. I think that's a huge part of it. But a lot of people still rely on talk radio for their news and information and entertainment. And so those folks are getting pretty much one viewpoint. This is also interesting because throughout the history of radio in America, there have
因此，事情就保持原样了，因为为什么任何自由派的新手，你知道，会在那种景观中找到立足之地呢？因为我根本不在寻找它。而且我很久以前就放弃了，所以这真的没关系。是的，绝对。我认为这是其中很大一部分。但很多人仍然依赖谈话广播获取新闻、信息和娱乐。所以这些人基本上只得到一种观点。这也很有趣，因为在整个美国广播史上，一直
been decisions that have helped increase the diversity of viewpoints and the voices and airwaves and decisions that have lessened that diversity. And that wasn't always stated as the goal of the decision, I'm sure it was just like free markets and whatever kind of nonsense they said. But that was the impact. It lessened diversity. Yeah, definitely. I mean, it was a decision to put policies in place that could help increase perspectives on the airwaves, and it was a decision to do away with them.
有决定帮助增加了观点的多样性和广播中的声音，也有决定减少了这种多样性。这并不总是被陈述为决定的目标，我相信那只是像自由市场之类的废话。但这就是影响。它减少了多样性。是的，绝对。我的意思是，这是一个制定政策的决定，可以帮助增加广播中的观点，而废除它们也是一个决定。
Like the market is not neutral or natural, like leaving things to the market is also a design choice. The erasure of those civil rights era broadcast victories that gave some local input and local control. The end of the fairness doctrine, allowing massive consolidation with India industry, those decisions helped make it so that the farthest reaching voices didn't need to be the most representative ones. And a voice like Rush Limba, whose rhetoric was extreme,
就像市场不是中立或自然的，把事情留给市场也是一种设计选择。对那些民权时代广播胜利的抹除，那些胜利曾提供了一些本地投入和本地控制。对“公平原则”的终结，允许行业内的大规模整合，这些决定使得传播最广的声音不需要是最具代表性的声音。而像拉什·林博这样言辞极端的声音，
didn't have to speak to everybody, or even a majority. But with behind the scene structure is working in your favor, you can bring the extreme into the mainstream and make it look organic. But it's not organic. Like you said, it's totally designed. I mean, these are decisions that people make, and you could make different decisions if you wanted a different outcome. All this stuff is so fascinating to me. I love radio. I got into this business because I love radio so much, and I live through much of this history. What are some of the other things you're talking about on your series for on the media? Yeah, so the series, The Divided Dial, takes an even deeper dive
不需要对每个人说话，甚至不需要对大多数人说话。但随着幕后结构对你有利，你可以把极端带入主流，并让它看起来很自然。但它不是自然的。就像你说的，它是完全设计的。我的意思是，这些是人们做出的决定，如果你想要不同的结果，你可以做出不同的决定。所有这些对我来说都太迷人了。我热爱广播。我进入这个行业是因为我太热爱广播了，我经历了这段历史的大部分。你在《媒体观察》（On the Media）系列节目中还谈到了哪些其他事情？是的，所以这个系列《分裂的表盘》（The Divided Dial）进行了更深入的挖掘
into how the right captured American talk radio, and how one company is quietly launching a conservative media empire from the airwaves. We talk about everything from the religious rights role and shaping what we hear on the radio to whether or not repeatedly broadcasting falsehoods is legal. As we said at the beginning, radio is still an incredibly influential format. But you know, it's you and I maybe know this because we both sort of got into this work because we love radio I started working in radio as well, but radio is not particularly glamorous medium and especially for mainstream media outlets
关于右翼是如何占领美国谈话广播的，以及一家公司是如何悄悄地从广播中建立一个保守派媒体帝国的。我们谈论了一切，从宗教右翼在塑造我们在广播中听到的内容中所扮演的角色，到反复广播虚假信息是否合法。正如我们在开头所说，广播仍然是一种极其有影响力的形式。但你知道，你和我可能知道这一点，因为我们俩都是因为热爱广播才进入这个行业的，我也开始在广播工作，但广播并不是一个特别迷人的媒介，尤其是对于主流媒体来说
They don't often report on what happens on the radio dial mm-hmm and just logistically like as you mentioned hours and hours a day 24-7 so many talkers. It's to call through it's hard to fact check it's hard to parse hard to analyze and it ends up getting overlooked despite it's still having a ton of power. Thank you Katie for bringing us this story and for the rest of the series I can't wait to listen to it. Yeah thank you so much Roman it was great to talk with you about this. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Katie Thornton, with help from Emmett Fitzgerald and Abigail Keel, edited by Kelly Prime, mixed by Amida Kanatra, music by a director of Sound, Swan Rial. Delaney Hall is a senior editor, Kirk Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team is Vivian Leigh, Christopher Johnson, Martin Gonzales, Chris Baroupe, Lashemadon, Jason Dillion,
他们并不经常报道广播表盘上发生的事情，嗯嗯，而且从后勤上讲，就像你提到的，每天24小时，每周7天，小时复小时，这么多谈话者。很难筛选，很难核实事实，很难解析，很难分析，尽管它仍然拥有巨大的权力，但它最终还是被忽视了。谢谢凯蒂（Katie）给我们带来这个故事，对于这个系列的其余部分，我迫不及待地想听了。是的，非常感谢你，罗曼，和你谈论这个真是太棒了。《99%无形》（99% Invisible）本周由凯蒂·桑顿（Katie Thornton）制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）和阿比盖尔·基尔（Abigail Keel）协助，凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）编辑，阿米达·卡纳特拉（Amida Kanatra）混音，音乐由声音总监斯旺·里亚尔（Swan Rial）制作。德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是高级编辑，柯克·科尔斯特德（Kirk Colstead）是数字总监。团队的其他成员是薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzales）、克里斯·巴鲁普（Chris Baroupe）、拉舍马顿（Lashemadon）、杰森·迪利恩（Jason Dillion）、
Jacob Multanada Medina, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Social banks this week to catch a Roger's executive producer of On the Media and tireless editor of Kati's series. Kati Thornton's series The Divided Dial is produced by WNYC's On the Media with support from the Fund for Investigative Journalism.
雅各布·穆尔塔纳达·梅迪纳（Jacob Multanada Medina）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）和我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。本周特别感谢《媒体观察》的执行制片人、凯蒂系列节目的不知疲倦的编辑凯特·罗杰斯（Katya Rogers）。凯蒂·桑顿的系列节目《分裂的表盘》由WNYC的《媒体观察》制作，并得到了调查新闻基金（Fund for Investigative Journalism）的支持。
You can find on the media at onthemedia.org. Four of the series' five episodes are out now. The finale is out soon. It's available in the On the media feed wherever you get your podcasts. And you can follow along with Katie's other work on her website. It's Katie Thornton.com or on Instagram. It's Katie Thornton. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence like 13 years ago and has never changed. It's that good. We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM Podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building.
你可以在onthemedia.org找到《媒体观察》。该系列五个剧集中的四个现在已经发布。大结局很快就会出来。它可以在你获取播客的任何地方的《媒体观察》订阅源中找到。你可以在她的网站上关注凯蒂的其他作品。网址是KatieThornton.com或在Instagram上，是Katie Thornton。《99%无形》的标志是斯蒂芬·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）大约13年前创作的，从未改变过。它就是那么好。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦（Pandora building）。
And beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我，罗曼·马尔斯，或者@节目，99PI org。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接以及《99%无形》的每一集往期节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。